how do you make a great flag I'm going
to tell you in 60 seconds one start with
a rectangle with one two two proportions
don't make a square flag looking at you
Vatican City to use simple shapes and
maybe a silhouette to create symbolism
for what the flag represents never use
seals or complex designs that can't be
drawn by a child in several seconds
three keep the design simple while still
differentiating it from other flags for
use two or three colors that look good
together
you may want to consider using lighter
colors which tend to look better 5 a
good flag is recognizable backwards and
many other scenarios one trick to make
sure a flag can be recognized even when
sitting still on a pole rather than
flying in the wind is to make a unique
design element in the canton the top
left corner seem familiar well probably
because it is I hope you now know a
little bit more about vexillology if you
found this interesting follow the links
in the notes for some cool related pages
and sites good day